from Cali counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Dunkin Donuts in India and in
the US this is food Wars
[Music]
here in the US you can get your Donuts
in one six or a half dozen or twelve AKA
a dozen don't put that in there
here in India you can get your Donuts in
packs of one
three or six one U.S sticky glazed
donuts Indian glazed donut it weighs
49 grams 59 grams in the US we have four
sizes of hot coffee the small
the medium the large which Unfortunately
they forgot Duncan and the extra large
India our filter coffee comes in one
size this one if you're wondering what
filter coffee is it's one of the most
popular drinks here in India it's made
by taking a decoction of coffee mixing
it with sweetened milk and typically
when they're preparing it they pour it
from a huge height to create this froth
it's super delicious and it's very
strong it'll wake you right up in the
morning as for our other drinks they
come in two sizes either medium or large
this is an Americano let's wait to see
how much we got
I might have to go to the bathroom after
this
10.14 fluid ounces
if that's not enough for you Duncan's in
the US also has a box of joe which
contains a hundred ounces of hot coffee
and
you good
oh yeah
this should be the extra large in the US
we only have three iced coffee sizes the
small the medium and the large no extra
Lush but they did remember a large iced
coffee so thanks Duncans so the Duncan
India website says that they serve an
iced Americano but we asked three
Outlets here in Bengaluru and they said
no ice Americano we even asked them hey
can you put some ice in our Americano
they said no so if you really must have
an Americano that's iced from Dunkin you
have to take your own ice and go there
so what what what's the large but it's
supposed to be 32. I mean I think it's
yeah the cup says 32 supposed to be 32.
Yulie zoom in on that and shame this
business
32
[Music]
this is everything that you'll find in
the menu at Dunkin Donuts India that you
will not find in the US here is
everything you can get in a U.S Dunkin
Donuts you can't get in India let's
start off with this one it is called
choco Villa and I think it's called that
because it's a little triangle of
chocolate which looks like those houses
we used to draw as kids
oh my God yum it's filled with my
favorite donut feeling ever which is
Bavarian cream choco almond
mmm
it's okay it's filled with the Bavarian
cream again
with the cream
unreal on to the next one this is called
a chocoholic it's got a piece of KitKat
sticking through it I want to see if
it's one kicker bar if they've taken two
and they've sandwiched them together
let's pull from this end yeah I was
right
regular chocoholic this is the one for
you the inside is also got chocolatey
filling in there
chocolate is starting to hit me real
hard right now
this stuff is so sweet this is called
rainbow crunch
oh there's strawberry frosting on top so
this has a strawberry taste it's okay
it's a donut next up we have cookie
Delight it's called cookie Delight
because they've taken cookie pot and
smacked it on top this one's called
crispy crunch for people who have
Trypophobia this one is probably not for
you
oh my God this ain't it the crispy stuff
on top is just not working again however
they do have the Bavarian cream inside
I feel like there's a hurricane inside
my body right now next up we have a
donut called
the Jenny my fellow Indians will
recognize that there are gems on top
this is one of the most nostalgic
chocolates here in India and I've eaten
them since I was a kid
super yum
you'd think a kid would like them but I
can't even imagine a kid version of
myself liking something that's so
overdosed with sweetness and chocolates
is it Jimmy yes two Jammy also yes I'd
avoid so I thought this was all the
exclusive signatures but I've been told
that there are two more and let's start
off with this one it's called choco pop
it's got chocolate on top chocolate
sprinkles chocolate wavy line things and
it's full of chocolate it's very sweet
[Music]
ah
[Music]
all right and on to our last donut this
one is called the choco Berry bomb
that's actually quite nice it is
definitely cut the sweetness that I've
experienced there's like some Berry Jam
inside which is kind of tart and nice
the top is milk chocolate with shavings
of white chocolate whoa yeah it's a good
donut I wouldn't order it it's too much
all of this I would not order any of
these they're too much exclusive Donuts
you get in the US you can't get in India
now we're filming this the first week of
October of course the number one flavor
you get this month is pumpkin
yeah this tastes just like pumpkin pie
also you can get yourself a glazed
blueberry donut see look at that glaze
on top Blueberry dough on the inside
also delicious love that glazed
chocolate figured this was everywhere
right
so good ooh Boston cream the Ben Affleck
of donuts looks like a regular donut
doesn't it everyone in India but
the prize is cream on the inside
I know everyone likes Donuts I haven't
donut in a while but crap this is really
good one of my favorites I've cooked
with these double chocolate maybe my
favorite because it just did what they
had to do take a chocolate donut and put
that chocolate frosting I like right on
top of it a double thread oh these are
so good
I am in heaven hope nice strawberry
frosting with sprinkles you don't got
this this is like the Homer Simpson
donut right this is the the one you
always see him eating oh the vanilla
cream
gotta say don't think I've ever had this
one before
coming I was like Scarface over here I'm
just covered a little much
oh
God
here's some powder right here
powdered donut India you don't know what
this is come on it's a donut number one
right
also in the US you can get a vanilla
frosted with sprinkles and a bear claw
which unfortunately did not have at the
time of shooting this hang on
munchkins guys ain't got munchkins what
we have a variety of Munchkin flavors
but this one specifically is the pumpkin
munchkin and
mmm
tastes just like pumpkin pie fantastic
hey guys we're now on to a different
category of donuts called the all-time
favorites I took a quick hospital visit
and I'm completely fine now I'm sorry
about the madness from the previous set
of donuts um I'm fine now I don't know
what came over I mean okay so we'll
start off with uh this specimen over
here it's called the cookie cartwheel
adorable name and yes it does look like
a wheel I like how they put the White
Stripes
[Music]
yeah it's sweet next up on our list is a
donut that's not intimidating at all
it's only called death by chocolate
will this kill me probably not but will
this excuse me from diabetes if I eat
too much absolutely and for that reason
it's a win in my book if you thought
death by chocolate was scary
this is alive by chocolate in terms of
visual differences I can already tell
this one has more of a cookie crumble on
top they're very similar as expected I
will say this one is feels more like it
lifts your spirits and you feel more
alive and this one will probably put you
to sleep in a coma so death and Alive it
makes sense
[Music]
whoa on to the next one we have
something called very very
strawberry vanilla frosting on top it's
got some pink streaks and it looks to be
stuffed with strawberry jam which sounds
amazing especially after all this
chocolate overdose
it's sweet
oh my God it's nice though all right
it's time for our final donut and this
one is a bit of a boss battle so this is
a donut eclair it's called The Breakup
party eclair I guess because if you go
through a breakup this is what you end
up eating
so the first few bites were quite nice
they weren't as sweet and they didn't
feel as rich
but I realized most of the chocolate is
kind of centered towards the center of
the eclair and so it's a lot more
decadent into the closer you get great
for breakups great as a metaphor for
what you feel when you're going through
a breakup and as a donut itself
pretty average both hot and cold
espresso and coffee drinks in the US
have options for flavors you can add as
flavor shots which are unsweetened or
flavor swirls which are sweet and creamy
now flavors unique to the US include
shots of vanilla toasted almond
blueberry raspberry and coconut and
flavor swirls you can get French vanilla
and pumpkin so I went ahead and had each
one of those Swirls and shots added to
one coffee right here in front of me
we'll call it the food Wars drinkaroo I
don't know what it is all the flavors in
one drink the lady when I ordered it was
like really and I was like really
[Music]
oh God so bad oh whoa this will whoa oh
man
it's like there's like an electric
charge to at the end I don't quite
understand
[Music]
this is poison don't get it alright it's
time for drinks let's start off with the
cold options that we have here at Dunkin
India uh the first one is a classic
lemonade let's go ahead and try it it
looks very clear
that's nice it's refreshing they've not
made it too sweet and I kind of like it
next up we have a virgin mojito
I don't see why somebody would go to
Dunkin Donuts get a donut and then a
virgin mojito on the side quick point to
make you can get them in a small bottle
or you can even get them in larger
options next up we have two flavors of
iced tea we have lemon and Peach I'm
gonna try the peach
if I had to pick one of these this is
the one I'd go for
exclusive hot drinks here in the US we
have these three the first one is like a
specific coffee blend at Duncan called
Duncan midnights
oh wow that has oh that is power that's
strong wow it's like it's like really
strong I kind of love it moving on you
give yourself a chai latte India doesn't
have chai lattes
that's really good and of course a
matcha latte no not matcha I hate matcha
that's the green one right beverages
that taste like lawn clippings
mm-hmm
I hate it all right it's now time for
our milk based cold beverages here in
India we have a range of frappes some
ice shaken coffees let's start with the
frappes coffee
caramel and Hazelnut and they have a
seasonal flavor which is Alfonso mango
if you've not heard of the Alfonso
variety of mangoes it grows all over
here in India and it is the king of
mangoes you have to try it if you get a
chance I'm going to start off with this
one because I love mango flavored
anything
it's not bad next up we have some shaken
iced coffees uh in three flavors caramel
classic and hazelnut also the classic
flavored shaken iced coffee it's not as
sweet and I want to put this one on a
pedestal thank you
okay next up they also sell a iced mocha
and an iced latte it's time for the
chocolate milkshake and can I just say
it looks decadent
it's quite thick
um it's kind of grainy like you can
taste the graininess of the chocolate
which I like but I don't know if some
some people might not like that some
people might like really smooth
chocolate milkshakes okay so if you're
traveling to India and you must eat a
Dunkin I would recommend you have the
Alphonse so mango frappe if it's in
season but I would also say don't go to
Dunkin go to any Juice Shop you find
them all across India and they take
fresh mangoes and they make you a mango
milkshake that will blow your mind
they'll put actual pieces of Alfonso
pulp in there and you'll chew on it
while you drink your milkshake God sense
so then they made these two hours ago
I'm sorry assume they don't look like
this anyway we have these cold drinks in
the US to call Refreshers they're
actually pretty good surprisingly I'm
starting down here we have the
strawberry dragon fruit I am such a
child it's spelled
[Music]
s-t-r-a-w-d-r-g-n-f-r-t and all I could
think of was Dragon farts
well that's actually pretty good Peach
Passion Fruit
whatever tea I keep thinking part of
such a child
whoa
all the syrup like went to the bottom
it's like way stronger than it should be
yeah cause up top is really weak
somewhere in between there's a good sip
but I didn't find it anyway all right
Peach Passion Fruit coconut
oh but this is is that cool does that
work
okay
uh no
oh gross yeah the coconut ones are bad
keeping it up on the cool drinks you get
yourself a frozen coffee a frozen matcha
latte a frozen chocolate and of course
the culottas wait frozen hot chocolate
it's not just chocolate milk
oh man that is strong that is a
milkshake yo
it's not terrible it's this the flavor
is very strong this is apparently a blue
raspberry I think they have other
flavors but
once upon a time I worked at a movie
theater yes really when we figured out a
way to get into the syrup box because
found drinks with syrup and soda water
at the same time it mixes right when you
pour it in it was like a really dark
color and we dared each other drink it I
remember it was
so powerful I thought I was gonna throw
up and I'd never experienced anything
like that powerful flavored until today
surprise surprise Dunkin Donuts also
serves chai so you have two flavors this
is ginger chai and we have eliji chai
elaichi is
cardamom ginger in Hindi is adrak and
it's just such a beautiful word to say
oh my God
they've gone heavy on the ginger for
sure
as advertised these do taste like
elaichi which is cardamom and ginger
yeah they don't quite have the the soul
of a chai that you get on the roadside
but I really love how Duncan has tried
to do this makes you feel a little bit
more at home so thank you Duncan
sandwiches and wraps and bagels and
breakfast stuff oh my get a good look
India we have a huge selection of
non-donutty breakfast uh sandwiches
variety stuff you can get oh man I hit a
wall and I apologize
foreign
get yourself maple sugar bacon breakfast
sandwich we have these wake up wraps and
wake up wraps are I don't know really
phoned in breakfast tacos I don't know
how to describe it it's tortilla they
put the stuff they already had for their
sandwiches in there they fold it over
I'll just grab one you can get yourself
one and oh man this thing is like
hey everyone I'm watching this video in
the comments let me know I show you this
and then when I open it are you more
likely to eat this or less likely let me
know in the comments Duncan nobody wants
these you can get yourself a tomato
pesto grilled cheese Pesto's fine and
all but when something has pesto on it
you don't realize it doesn't look like
look at this green does that look like
we should go oh it's pesto or would you
be like oh I think that's moldy I also
got the grilled cheese oh
foreign
[Music]
breakfast sandwich yo these things so
solidified probably edible a few hours
ago I'll I'll take a bite of this
sausage egg and cheese
no not bad bacon egg and Juice somewhere
encased in this melted cheese is bacon I
assure you there's also a turkey sausage
egg and cheese somewhere oh you can also
get bagels at your Dunkin Donuts why I
don't know but you can get bagels plain
cinnamon raisin multigrain sesame seed
and this one everything and get yourself
some cream cheeses including Garden
veggie strawberry and plain also you can
get an avocado spread which they did not
include
Duncan India you're not gonna believe
this our Dunkin Donuts you can get a
side of
you can get a side of something called
snack and bacon what snack and bacon you
ask it is
a bag of bacon Bagel minis you can get
plain and everything Bagels here's one
right now I think these have cream
cheese inside of them
yeah
I don't think I've ever had one of these
before
that's not a bad idea not bad guys also
in the U.S you can order hash browns now
at Dunkin Donuts apparently you get
these what are we call these omelette
bites uh you get bacon egg and cheese or
egg white and veggie come on this is
straight taken from from Starbucks right
we went to the Dunkin India website and
over there on the menu they claim to
sell burgers and a few sides like nachos
however we went to the outlets and the
manager said that they're phasing out
all Savory food in Duncan nationally but
he was kind enough to make us one single
non-ridge burger just so that we get to
taste what it would have been like it
has a whole chicken piece in there which
is already kind of nice some onions
looks like Tandoori mayo and the bun
looks pretty tasty
foreign
oh my God
that's actually really good I've done
many episodes of food Wars tasted many
burgers from restaurants that are
literally burger joints and this
literally Rivals those Barbers this is
pretty good what's happening Duncan okay
so the fact is that Duncan has actually
scaled down massively here in India in
Bangalore where we're filming there used
to be 20 Dunkin Donut outlets now there
are only three so rumor has it that
Duncan might be phasing out of India in
general and the decision is going to be
made in the coming weeks so maybe this
video is the last remaining Legacy of
Duncan in India and this is probably the
last burger that has ever eaten oh here
this might be the guys this might be the
last Burger ever consumed from Dunkin
Donuts here in India
foreign
this large Americano is rupees 139 which
is currently 1.71 US dollars but keep in
mind at the time that we're filming this
the Indian Rupees at an all-time low so
hopefully things will get better and
this won't cost so much that same drink
in the US is 3.69 or
293.44 rupees that's a 63.9 percent
increase in price okay so the biggest
menu item that we have here in India is
our box of six now you can get two
categories you can get Classic Donuts
which are a lot simpler and it'll cost
you rupees 399 or you can get the
favorites Donuts which we have here
which are a lot more extravagant and
will cost you rupees 499 which amounts
to USD 6.12 right now if you want 12
donuts you need to get two boxes of six
which will cost you rupees 998. for food
our biggest menu item is a dozen donuts
18.73 or 1004
492.85 rupees
thank you our biggest drink is the box
of joe Avella it's the most expensive
single menu item 27.48 or
2190.25 rupees now in India we have
something called a Vada which is pretty
much a donut but it's Savory and it's
fried and I want to say that those costs
around 20 rupees while this original
glazed that I've bitten into a few times
costs 85 rupees so it's important to
note this price difference and people
here will definitely think about that
before buying something like this
[Music]
nikhail stop eating the props
okay so Dunkin Donuts India has not
released any of the nutritional info out
for the public and they've not gotten
back to us when we asked them for
information as of now however I can
confirm that one donut is probably less
nutritious than one salad
let's talk about Duncan U.S nutrition
starting with the glazed donut in the US
it has 360 calories 22 grams of fat 10
grams of saturated fat 420 milligrams of
sodium or 20 39 grams of carbs and 18
grams of sugar and let's compare that
donut on to this one the Boston cream in
the USA a Boston cream is 270 calories
11 grams of fat 320 milligrams of sodium
39 grams of carbs and 18 grams of sugar
a Dunkin Donuts large ice Dunkin dark
roast coffee with cream and sugar in the
U.S is 260 calories 12 grams of fat and
37 grams of carbs now assuming that the
iced coffee is the same in the U.S and
India getting a large iced coffee with
cream and sugar and both the glazed and
a Boston cream donut has 890 calories
that's 35.6 percent of your daily
calorie intake yo
foreign Dunkin Donuts has not released
any of their ingredients to the public
however there is one huge difference
between the U.S and Indian donuts and
that is that the Indian Donuts are all
eggless this is because a huge
percentage of Indians are vegetarian
especially Hindus and so they even
consider eating egg as non-veg food and
so yeah most fast food restaurants have
decided to not use egg in any of their
foods to make it more accessible to a
larger part of India but the US does
have it out of sight so I will share
with you the ingredients right now first
up the coffee regardless if you're
getting it hot or cold if you get a
plaque it's going to be 100 arabica
coffee nice now if you want to add cream
and sugar to it then you are adding milk
cream to sodium phosphate stabilizer
sodium citrate as a stabilizer and sugar
if you're going to be adding flavor to
your coffee drink one flavor you can get
both India and the US is caramel and in
the US our caramel flavor is made up of
all this
in the US our standard glazed donut is
made up of all of these things
you think that's a lot here's everything
in our Boston cream donuts yikes that's
a lot of words
hey everyone it's Harry Kash from the
food both team I finally got to meet my
co-host Joe Avella for a cool new
project we're working on called Food
Tours here's a trailer for it now
[Music]
oh yeah it's so good man
incredible oh my God I don't
can I shop you Joe
I quite like this
oh yeah
yo what's up with that egg over there
what is that that's the gherkin oh what
is it really it's literally the guy the
girl again
people of the internet you cannot expect
me to pick this up with my hands
oh man at this point I think I could
race
a small car
yeah like one of those small cars I
could raise one of those
how many more Donuts do we have because
I'm taking on a cheetah at the end of
this episode